today let's start our little look
tree we've actually been here before
the theme I want to develop because I
want us to put us back as if you are
entering the labor force around nineteen
thirty you've just come off what we call
the roaring 20s and while you should
feel better because the economy was
growing so well in the 1920s and profits
were up and the stock market was at
record levels you probably don't feel
very optimistic because despite all this
good news family income was falling in
the 1920s as it is today most of the
income went to the top 10% just as it is
today in our society and then of course
1929 comes along and we get the great
stock market crash and everything starts
to fall to pieces at that point over the
next several years if you were entering
the labor force or an existing more
mature worker you were expected to lose
between eight to twenty percent of your
income if you got unemployed over twenty
five percent of the labor force you were
really in dire straits there was steady
loss of income especially for those
people who were working in small
businesses are working on the farm well
this created all kinds of pressures and
it led to the election of a new
president president franklin delano
roosevelt was elected in 1932 with
pressure from the population to bring us
out of the depression and find new ways
to protect workers jobs and incomes well
he had quite a job on his hand so many
people out on the streets looking for a
job homeless a new term was invented
something called Hoovervilles people
pitching tents in our major cities
because they had nowhere else to live
the great Dust Bowl occurred so people
from Oklahoma and Texas started to
migrate with their families to
California in search of a better life
The Grapes of Wrath written to describe
the plight of these people who were
moving to try to find a better job and a
better opportunity was probably the best
selling book about that time and so
something was needed well we actually
did get some change in national policy
this is a picture of the first woman
cabinet member in the United States
Frances Perkins who was chosen to be the
Secretary of Labor by President
Roosevelt but she warned him when he
interviewed her about the job she said
mr. president you don't want to choose
me as a secretary unless you're willing
to think about new forms of unemployment
insurance and minimum wages and social
security for people when they retire
well Roosevelt said that's exactly why I
want you for this job and so we did see
what was called the New Deal come to
pass in the 1930s with a lot of work
with the Congress and with the Roosevelt
administration and building on many of
the innovations that occurred at state
and local government levels in the
previous 20 years we got much of the
labor legislation that still is the
foundation for labor policy today
starting with unemployment insurance
unemployment insurance was first put in
place to try to provide temporary
assistance for people who were out of
work who would get called back to work
when the economy got better well that
worked for a long time but today almost
nobody who gets unemployed expects to be
called back job loss is permanent and so
we need to update the unemployment
insurance system it's not just to
provide temporary financial assistance
for people out of work we need to help
them find new jobs and get new training
opportunities and assistance to move to
where the jobs happen to be in 1938 we
passed the first minimum wage and
overtime legislation called the Fair
Labor Standards Act 25 cents an hour was
the minimum wage at that time that has
moved up now to seven dollars and
twenty-five cents but the bad news is it
hasn't kept up with inflation so we are
worse off today at that level than we
were in nineteen the mid 1960s and we
need to update the minimum wage at the
national level to keep up with the rate
of inflation in the growing cost of
living the same with rules
over time through the 40s 50s and 60s
over sixty percent of salaried workers
were still eligible for overtime today
that number is down to about ten percent
and so we've got to find ways to allow
low wage salary workers assistant
managers at McDonald's in other places
to be able to get overtime if they're
working 50 and 60 hours a week as many
of them are the National Labor Relations
Act provided for collective bargaining
legislation in the nineteen thirty-five
Act that law promised workers a right to
gain access to a union and collective
bargaining it worked quite well for many
years but today it's broken beyond
repair today if an employer wants to
resist a workers right to organize over
ninety percent of the time the employer
is going to win and then workers will be
frustrated so we need to find new ways
to modernize that law to provide workers
with the voice that they want we passed
the Social Security Act in 1935 that
provided a retirement income for all
workers based on the hours that they
worked in the labor force over the years
and the salaries that they earned and
that law still provides a good
retirement income for most workers boy
that law to needs to be updated because
we're living longer were not able to
cover all of the debts of the next
generation and therefore we're going to
have to tweak that law but in order to
avoid going bankrupt with Social
Security over the next 20 years all of
these laws need to be updated to catch
up with the changing workforce and the
changing nature of work but perhaps we
have to go farther maybe it's also time
to pass some new legislation to
recognize that today it takes two
working parents to earn a decent living
for their families so maybe it's time
for the United States to become the last
country in the developed world to
provide some form of paid family leave
if we have to stay home and take care of
a sick child or take care of an elderly
parent that needs help it's time to
modern
our Labor and Employment Relations
policies so yes we've been there before
in the 1930s and we can do it again if
you put your creative ideas and your
collective energy together to modernize
employment policies to fit today's
economy and today's workforce
you